انفجار ارتجاجي حاد
ثم انطفأت لقطة الكاميرا الصحفية في جبهة عون
بعد لحظات من الفوضى
واشتعلت النيران في سيارة. أدت هذه الضربة المزدوجة في جنوب
لبنان يوم 13 تشرين الأول/أكتوبر إلى مقتل مصور
فيديو رويترز عصام عبد الله وإصابة
ستة صحفيين آخرين ثم دوي
أصابنا خرج من  لا يشير
تحليل الطب الشرعي الذي أجرته شبكة سي إن إن إلى أن نيران
الدبابات الإسرائيلية هي التي قتلت عبد الله
وأصابت الآخرين في غارتين بفارق 37
ثانية. وتؤكد النتائج التي توصلت إليها شبكة سي إن إن
التقارير الصادرة عن مؤسستين إخباريتين رويترز
وفرانس برس ومجموعتين لحقوق الإنسان، منظمة
العفو الدولية
وهيومن رايتس
ووتش.  بعد ذلك الهجوم، ذكرت شبكة سي إن إن
أن هؤلاء الصحفيين كانوا
يرتدون سترات واقية من الرصاص تحمل علامات واضحة،
كما نقلت شبكة سي إن إن عن
مصدر أمني لبناني أفاد بأن
مروحية أباتشي إسرائيلية شوهدت فوق
موقع الهجوم في وقت قريب من
الهجوم، مما يشير إلى أن القوات الإسرائيلية
كانت قادرة على رؤية الصحفيين.  كنا
في منطقة مكشوفة، كنا جميعًا
نرتدي خوذاتنا وستراتنا فقط نقوم
بعملنا في تغطية الاشتباكات، وكنا
نحافظ على مسافة آمنة من
خط المواجهة، وزعمت وكالة فرانس برس وهيومن رايتس ووتش أن
ضربات 13 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول كانت
متعمدة من جانب القوات المسلحة.  ووصفت منظمة
هيومن رايتس ووتش العسكرية ما حدث بأنه
جريمة حرب على ما يبدو في بيان
لرويترز،
وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي، ريتشارد HEC، نقلا عن
بيان منفصل من الجيش الإسرائيلي، إن
القوات الإسرائيلية كانت ترد على إطلاق
صاروخ مضاد للدبابات على  كان هناك
قلق في ذلك الوقت بشأن احتمال
تسلل الإرهابيين إلى إسرائيل
في تلك اللحظة، وقال البيان إن
التواجد في هذه المنطقة أمر خطير،
والحادث قيد المراجعة حاليًا
وفقًا للجنة حماية
الصحفيين، وقد قُتل ما لا يقل عن 63 صحفيًا
في إسرائيل و  غزة
منذ 7 أكتوبر، الأغلبية المطلقة
90٪ هم صحفيون فلسطينيون محليون،
تقول اللجنة إن هذه
الحرب بالذات التي تغطي حتى الآن
حوالي شهرين فقط كانت
الفترة الأكثر دموية للصحفيين منذ أن
بدأت اللجنة. جمع البيانات قبل 31 عامًا
ما يجعل هذا الصراع
خطيرًا بشكل فريد بالنسبة لهم  الصحفيين
المخاطر الهائلة التي يواجهها في المقام الأول
الصحفيون الفلسطينيون المحليون
الذين يعيشون في غزة أه الذين ليس لديهم
ملاذ آمن ولا مخرج، يقول شاري منصور من
لجنة حماية الصحفيين،
يجب على كبار المسؤولين الأمريكيين ممارسة المزيد من
الضغط على الإسرائيليين فيما يتعلق
بالضحايا في صفوف الصحفيين
قال وزير الخارجية أنتوني بلينكين إنه من
المهم إجراء
تحقيق شامل في حادثة 13 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
ودعا السكرتير الصحفي للبنتاغون
الإسرائيليين إلى حماية
المدنيين الأبرياء، بمن فيهم الإعلاميون
بريان تود سي إن إن
واشنطن